[音楽]
5年ほど前
私は友達の誘いデー
と私の足助チクリ米作り体験に来ました
その時幸か不幸か小沢さんという元気なおちーさんであります
この小沢さんが私の人生を劇的に変えた人
米作り体験なのにイノシシの話ばかりしてくるんです
小澤さんの敷地にを変えたイノシシの織屋
イノシシが掘り返したた肌などを見せられ
昼食にはイノシシのスペアリブが用意され
それを食べながらまたイノシシ被害の話
そんなことが数回続く家
初めてイノシシを見ました
話には聞いていたけど実にするのは初めて
イノシシが走ったと伝えると
とってクレーや桃澤さん
この時初めてイノシシを取らなきゃって思ったんです
すぐにスマホで猪取る資格と検索し
狩猟免許があることを知りました
わなの狩猟免許がわかったこと小澤さんに伝えるとすぐに近所の量産を紹介してくれ
その漁師さんから
イノシシのおりのかけ方やイノシシの取り方を教えてもらいました
数字すると
その霊さんから電話がかかってきたんですイノシシが檻に入ったからこう言って
足助に行くと
イノシシが6頭もおりにかかっていて
1頭ずつよりです止めていくからねって言われました
狩猟免許試験は
試験会場でペーパー試験とバラの仮説の実技のみ
このときの私はここにいる皆さんにやりが私てはいじゃあ今からイノシシをやりでとめ
てくださいねと言ってるのと同じです
初めて仕留めたのが一つの檻に入ったイノシシの子供さん等
とにかく怯えて走りもあるので
なかなかうまく仕留める事が出来ず
1基という叫び声が響き渡ります
かわいいの趣旨の子どもが走り回るの
私も必死で槍で刺し
やりから伝わってくるイノシシの心臓の鼓動がだんだん弱っていくことを感じて
それでもイノシシが暴れるからやりから手を離すと自分が怪我をする
これが命を張っていることなんだなと感じました
イノシシの解体をするとき小沢さんが立ち会い
腹を避けています
やったこともないし
気持ち悪いし臭いけど
お腹を切ると
生姜で論というレッテルんです
そこですかさず小沢さんが腹の中に手を入れロ
何を感じるって聞いてくるんです
感触は気持ち悪いし
臭いし
我慢して手を入れるとすごく熱い
あったかい
って答えると
それが命
今まで生きてきた命を奪うことなんだ
だからちゃんと食べてやらなきゃいかんっって言われました
帰りの車の中で
キーキーという声が耳から離れません
命が奪われる恐怖から
あんな風に書くのかな
こんな思いはもうやだなって思いました
私の漁師人生初日はそんな風に始まりました
未だに思いではありません
誰もゆっくり優しく指導してくれる人なんていなくて
とにかく勢いで言われるがままにやっていました
自分がこれほど必要だと思われたことがなくて
とにかく仕事としてこなす日々
いつでも辞めたいって思うくらい心が強くてしんどい
だけどイノシシはたくさん捕まります
そのうち一体自分が何をやってるんだろうと自問自答する機会が増えました
1週間お寺に通い昼食に話を聞いてもらったことがあります
妻を食べに来ただけの動物の命を張って
いいことなのか
そんな疑問に昼食は
命を奪うことを罪だと思っているんであれば
それは罪ではない
命と向き合っているんだから
炭とは自分がやっていることを悪いと思わない
それが罪なんだという言葉をかけてくれたんです
心が少し軽くなりました
そしてふと私がやる前は一体どうしてたんだろう
思ったんです
当時私は刈谷に住んでいて足助まで1時間以上かかります
免許をとってこんなにも連絡は来るって事は私以外にやる人がいないってこと
その答えは聞くだけでもつらいものでした
とったイノシシの子どもや小動物は漁師さんが仕留めてくれないと
川に沈めて死ぬのを待つんだそうです
野生の動物は生命力をすごくて
なかなか知りません
耳について離れなかったあの
きっきーという音を聞くんだそうです
やっと静かになったからってそのままにしておけない
うめなきゃいけない
高齢者が多い足助地区では野菜を作るよりはるかに重労働です
野菜を守る
には大きすぎる対価を支払っているように感じました
命はば痛くない私と野菜を守りたい人たち
私の中の葛藤がなくなるわけではありません
けれど近所の人が最悪から家に来て
イノシシをとってくれ
とった飲みに来たり先輩漁師からお前がやらなきゃ誰が農家を守るんだ
と喝を入れられたりする旅
私がやらなきゃなんだなって思います
あまり知られてはいませんが私の農作物被害金額は
1.2億へ
ただでさえ農業人口が減少している中
頑張っている人には続けてもらいたいし
イノシシの以外から少しでも守ってあげたい
初めてイノシシを見た時のに
やっぱり私は取らなきゃって思うんです
そしてみんなのためにイノシシは取るけど
もっと子の命と向き合いたいと思うようになりました
家畜の牛や豚は命を奪うけど食べることで感謝される
だけど野生のイノシシやシカは
命を奪うけど埋められるだけ
とても命を粗末にしているように感じました
調べてみるとー
全国平均で9割以上も処分されています
ジビエとして調べているイノシシやシカでさえも全体の7%しか食べられていないです
実は野生動物を食べるためにはとても高いハードルがあるんです
まず仕留めた後
獣専用の解体処理施設に運ばなければいけません
しかも1時間以内に
運良く運べたとしてもその解体処理施設のスペースの問題で拒否されることもあります
と私だけでも1.2億円の農業被害があるのに
解体処理施設は愛知県に立った6つしかないんです
昔は
山菜や野菜などしかなくて漁師がとってくる日野氏は
タンパク質が摂れる貴重な山の恵みだったと小澤さんは言います
だから処理施設がなくたって漁師がさがいてみんなで食べていた
そういえばうちのおじいちゃんも
自分で撮ったハトやスズメを焼いて私に食べさせてくれてました
私が大事に育てていた
うさぎのみみちゃんが鍋になったこともあります
泣き桜私を精選戦争系経営者であるおじいちゃんは
戦争が始まったら食べるものがなくなって何でも食べていけなきゃいけない
命をいただくということを教えてくれました
大好きなおじいちゃんの言葉を抜きながら飲み込んで一緒にミミちゃん美味しく食べた
ことを覚えています
ここはああ
戦場ではないけれど
山の恵みを埋めるなんて
もったいない
だったら
昔のように漁師の私がさばいて食べればいいんだ
足助は
猪だけじゃないはず
どんな動物が取れるんだろう
そう思った私は狩猟鳥獣48種類から
実際に34種類を食べてみました
美味しいと思うものからえーっって思うものまで
一番美味しいと思ったのは
洗いごまです
そしてまもなくして私はそんなおいしい尻をたくさんの方に食べてもらえるように
シリアカフェをオープンさせました
安全に美味しいお肉を食べていただけるように
カフェの鳥に隣に解体処理施設も作りました
農家さんからのイノシシをとってくれという悲痛な声に
資料者人口付やつ活動や
新人漁師を育成するための npo
漁師仲間と一緒に立ち上げました
こうやって言うとものすごく割り切ってテキパキと活動しているように見えますか
罪のない動物の命を奪うことに抵抗がなくなったわけではありません
私たちは
農家さんの被害を少しでも減らしたい
里に下りてきてしまった
動物の命を奪うことはやめられません
せめてその肉を美味しくいただく
命を粗末にせずにー
命をいただくことで
大事にしたいっ
だから農家さんに感謝されるように壁で美味しく地 b を食べていただくと
よかったって思うんです
それでも私が深くして解体してカフェで提供しても微々たる業にしかすぎません
未だ9割以上が処分されているのが事実です
チビへカフェや npo などまだまだ始まったばかりの活動ですか
これは算定的なやり方でしかありません
私の夢は私の仕事がなくなること
鳥獣被害を防ぐためだけの理由で野生の動物を多く殺処分をするという仕事がなくなる
ことです
それは人にとっても動物にとっても
豊かな生活になっていくと思うからです
今目の前の生活のために鳥獣被害と戦うの仕方がないことです
そこからは逃れられません
けれど
私たちは
昔では手に入れられなかった
様々な武器を手に入れました
それは情報共有という武器です
例えばここ愛知県ではしかの目撃マップを作って公開することで被害に予防に役立つ
システムを作っています
家の解体処理施設もクラウドファンディングを使って情報共有することで多くの皆さん
から御支援を頂き作ったものです
頻繁に sns を更新するのも里山の日常や漁師の生活を少しでも皆さんに伝えたい
から
即座に多くの情報をみんなで共有して
アクションを起こすことで解決する
多くの人々が知ることで
私たちは新しい
共存の居合を作れる可能性を秘めているんです
そのための第一歩として私は鳥獣被害による
命のいただくといのちをいただく大切さをこれからも伝えていきたいと思います
ありがとうございました
[音楽]
[拍手]